welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and why the hell are London New York and
Hong Kong so damn special in the MCU huh
I mean they're important enough for
wizards of cometage to plant Magical
Real Estate on right but why and how are
these locations absolutely crucial to
maintaining the shields that protect the
planet from huge dark threats like
dormammu well what if I told you that
MCU phase 4 has been secretly laying
down the hints that answer this very
mysterious question that has been
lingering in the MCU for years now let's
dive into those details my nerd babies
because I have a feeling reintroducing
Daredevil into the MCU 616 Universe
means a lot more than you may know but
first do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can pick up
one of our new latest Obsession shirts
or one of our amazing nerd auctions just
in time for the holiday season so head
on over to new rockstars merch.com so
you can be that person today alright
gang so what the hell is so damn
important about London New York and Hong
Kong in the MCU like what makes these
locations places of power and why do the
sanctums need to be at these locations
in order to maintain that Golden Shield
that protects Earth from dark threats
like dormamma I mean hell with King the
Conqueror on his way to commit various
chronological war crimes across the
Multiverse I think it's a fair time to
consider just how the planet's magical
security system is against those dark
Forces of the Multiverse and I think the
key phase four in Phase five projects to
understanding just what Marvel Studios
is planning are the following eternals
for London Echo for New York and Chung
Chi and Iron Fist for Hong Kong With a
Little Help from Netflix's Defender
series because I believe the key power
source for Earth's great protective
barriers are the bones of Earth's past
brake protectors dragons you know like
the great protector from Chung Chi
because I have a strong feeling that
London New York and Hong Kong are all
cities built upon the magical remains of
the protective dragons of Earth's past
the same yellow magic that courses
within the red dragon skills that
protect the Warriors of talo and form
the door that kept the dweller in
darkness at Bay and secretly the same
magic that courses through shangchi's
rings and it's all mainly thanks to
Marvel Studios bringing a certain Man
Without Fear into the phone cause
Daredevil's inclusion into the MCU who
threw both Spider-Man no way home and
now She-Hulk makes the events of Netflix
Daredevil series Canon which is super
important here because the Defender
series is when we learn a massively
important facts that New York City
itself is built upon the bones of a
dragon from Earth's distant past dragon
bones that the evil organization the
hand desperately wanted in order to make
life-sustaining Resurrection Elixir you
know the kind that made leaders of the
handles was super long and be able to
resurrect badasses like Elektra so that
she can keep on killing again with
Elektra so good at killer alright guys
I'm on camera a lot so I have to see my
face a lot so you think I'd have to put
a lot of effort into my skincare routine
but I know because I use geology geology
is a 15-time award-winning personalized
skin care company recognized in
hypebeast birdie Men's Health Esquire
and ask man grooming Awards with over 6
thousand five star reviews that is a lot
of thousands at six of them and they've
recently expanded to offer products for
pretty much whatever you need all you've
got to do is take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology figures out
your routine for you if you need Hair
Care not me use geology's co-wash
especially formulated cream cleanser
that removes buildup and cleanses the
hair without the big lather or harsh
ingredients of typical shampoo and for
the rest of your shower routine you can
use their body washes that are free of
harsh ingredients smell great and are
refillable and for after the shower
protect your skin from environmental
stressors with vitamin c and e for Relic
serum to keep your skin looking young
and healthy and then a bit of
dermatologist tested aluminum-free
deodorant that quite honestly smells
great like I've gotten so many
compliments from the ladies specifically
so and right now for a limited time
geology is hooking our audience up with
an absolutely insane insanity if you use
code new rockstars that will give you an
additional 70 off their award-winning
skin care trial set that's seven zero
percent seventy that discount applies
whether you're stocking up for yourself
or stuffing someone else's stocking
instead either way geology has you
covered check out their awesome gift
sets featuring all your favorite geology
products to get started just click the
link in the description take a 30 second
diagnostic quiz and their team of
dermatologists will design a
personalized routine just for you that
ships directly to your door I believe
that this is the energy that is the main
basis for why New York is a place of
power in the MCU and why Sorcerers like
agamoto are wreck to the Samsung there
but even just as importantly I also
think that this is why the echo series
will be so crucial for the future of the
MCU because this series will likely go
into North America's history with
dragons and the dragons of Native
American Myth a thread that I believe
was secretly teased during a really
quick flashback sequence of a young echo
in the Hawkeye series
no maybe they are but dragons live in a
different world
[Music]
well that would make them stronger Echo
herself has a very strong interest in
Dragons and I have a feeling that
interesting dragons is going to carry on
over to her series you'll learn a lot
more about the dragons of Native
American and this could be the same for
the London sanctum as well as I think
the first eternals movie actually teases
this take a look
is that the Ebony Blade Excalibur
Arthur always didn't have a crush on you
with that super subtle moment eternals
confirmed that King Arthur and his
legendary dragon slaying blade Excalibur
exist within the MCU while also teasing
the Ebony Blade a curse blade wielded by
King Arthur's cousins sir Reginald a
blade that would drive sir Reginald mad
for the post-credits scene with Dean
Whitman but these are two dragon slaying
blades used in England in the past
implying that dragons existed in the
past and that there are dragon bones
underneath London as well much like Echo
will probably cover the dragons of North
America I have a strong belief that both
eternals too and the inevitable Black
Knight project will dive into England's
past dealings with mythical dragons and
how the bones of all those dragons have
made London a place of power in the
world likely by having Dan Whitman go on
a time traveling Journey To The Past
like he's done a couple times in the
comics I mean this is the time traveling
Multiverse Saga after all or anything
could happen and this of course leaves
the Hong Kong symptom in China which is
where I believe Xiang Chi and Iron Fist
will commit as China is where portals to
both the magical lands of both Tallow
and kunlun can be found considering that
we learned from chongqi that talo is
filled with creatures from Chinese myths
there is a big chance here that Earth
has had beastly Visitors by at least one
of these Realms possibly even the dragon
shall allow the undying the very source
of the iron fist's yellow power and
again considering that Daredevil and the
Defenders seem to be canon in the MCU
616 Universe to some degree then the
legend of Iron Fist will likely be as
well so I definitely expect shung Chi
and Iron Fist to continue the secret
Narrative of protective yellow dragon
power in the MCU it's all Dragon cheat
but basically in summary I believe that
agamoto planted sanctums in these three
places on the planet so that these
sanctums could channel the dragon qi
energy radiating off of the bones of
Earth's past Dragon visitors allowing
them to continue protecting the planet
even in death Eternal great protectors
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
Messer table on Twitter if you guys want
to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly you can follow new rock
stars wherever we are on the social
media so thank you guys again for
watching this video I love you guys so
much I'll see you guys next time
foreign
[Music]